look at this map of all of the places in
the world Vladimir Putin can't go it's
the countries in green let me explain
the international criminal court is this
court in the Netherlands that is in
charge of Prosecuting like the worst war
criminals in our world they recently put
a warrant out for the arrest of Vladimir
Putin for his war crimes in Ukraine
which means that everyone who has signed
on to the international criminal court
all of these countries must arrest
Vladimir Putin if he enters their
country and guess who just joined
Russia's neighbor and old Ally Armenia
Armenia did this because they're worried
about a whole other issue with aeran
which I explained in another video but
in doing so they made Russia very angry
because they're basically validating the
court who wants to arrest Vladimir Putin
Russia used to support Armenia but
they've kind of been absent lately
largely because they're focused on
Ukraine so Armenia is like I have
nothing to lose by signing on and kind
of estranging myself with Russia they
signed on they're part of the IC and
Russia's not happy about it if you want
to understand global politics follow
along for more